Awesome. So my name's Kelly shoemaker.
I'm the head distiller for hanger one. Um,
we're up in Alameda, California
on the formal naval air station.
So just up the way,
I'm actually relatively new to California.
Um,
I moved here to join hangar one about
three years ago from Denver, Colorado.
I actually started distilling it.
Stranahan's Colorado whiskey and
Denver go Broncos. I like that shirt.
Um,
so I started my career in whiskey and
the time that I spent making whiskey
really had an opportunity to learn
pretty much every aspect of distillation,
everything from tours and tastings
to grain selection to mashing,
fermenting, distilling, barrel
maturation, bottling. Um,
there's so many awesome aspects
that go into making delicious,
delicious beverages.
Um,
but what I have the opportunity to come
join hangar one here in the bay area.
I was really excited.
Hangar one is a brand that's really well
known for using fresh ingredients and
partnering with local farmers to
source those ingredients. And that was,
that was something that,
uh,
I found really exciting and trigging
and that would be a great challenge.
So here at hanger one where I am now,
um,
we working with our local communities
and local farmers is pretty much at the
center of everything we do.
We source grain and wine from local folks.
We work with farmers throughout California
to source the fruits in botanicals
for our flavored vodka and we even get
some water from our friendly neighborhood
fog for fog point. But you
know, we'll talk a little
bit more about that in a bit.
Um, part of this collaboration
with local suppliers, uh,
leads to partnerships with
like minded individuals.
So Chris is with me here today.
I'm Chris from fog quest and uh,
he'll talk a little bit about fog and fog
water and how we use fog to make vodka.
But what, what we're going to
touch on today is a few things.
We're going to talk a little bit
about innovation and Vodka, um,
innovation and distilling.
And our most recent innovation at hanger
one fog point thought go. All right.
So before I get too crazy
talking about fog point,
you guys probably would like to
know how vodka is made, right?
A lot of people have this perception of
a VOD could be in a spirit that's vodka
because it comes from potatoes.
This is not actually the case.
Vodka can be made from
just about anything.
If it can be fermented to create alcohol,
it can be made into vodka.
So their grain vodkas out there,
there's corn vodka, there's fruit vodka,
there's even a guy making vodka from milk,
so people get really creative with it.
Um, basically the way to make vodka is
you start with your fermented material and
then you need to distill it to 190 proof
hundred 90 [inaudible], 95% alcohol.
It's pretty spicy stuff, right? Um,
the idea is to reach towards a clean,
odorless, flavorless profile. That's
actually in the federal definition. Um,
we don't want it to be 100% odorless
and flavorless what have a nod to our
starting ingredients and put a lot of
work into sourcing really good stuff.
We want you to be able to taste it.
So the 5% that sneaks through
it with that 95% alcohol,
it's going to carry through a little
bit of character from our starting
ingredients and it hangar one that's
mid western grains and California wine
grapes. Um, so you guys just saw
a picture of this still behind me.
We've also got a photo right here.
Distilling in a nutshell is the act
of boiling are fermented material,
so we're using California wine grapes.
In our case that's wine and
as we boil that material,
the alcohol portion of it has a
lower boiling point than the water,
which means that the alcohol steam is
going to rise up off that solution before
the water allowing us to collect it and
condense it back down into more pure
liquid alcohol.
Now you see this still behind me.
It's got a lot of little windows and
things on it. We have to get to 190 proof.
It's pretty important part of being vodka,
so that doesn't look like a whiskey still.
That's specifically a vodka still.
The reason it is specifically a VOD
Casteel is because the towers next to the
pot eat contain a series
of small chambers.
That's what those windows representatives,
small chambers and an Asian,
those chambers,
the vodkas forced to go from a liquid
to a gas to a liquid to a gas each time
leaving behind more water,
leaving behind impurities and making its
way to the collection tanks at the end,
at 190 proof.
Now distilling is what people think
about when they think about making vodka,
right? Distilling is the
most important part. Um,
crazy thing is if we're
distilling up to 190 crew,
if you guys want to drink it at
that high of approved, right, it's,
we have to have water.
Water is actually 60% of vodka.
We're going to have water back into our
body to bring it down to that bottle
strength. So there's actually more water
in your alcohol than there is alcohol.
A lot of the times,
another fund fund,
the party fact you can
share with your friends. Um,
so for most of our vodkas are straight
vodka on all of our fruit bod coast.
We're using reverse osmosis water.
Reverse osmosis water is so clean that
it allows our ingredients to shine.
It allows all of the different nuances
and the flavor profile of these awesome
ingredients we're using to shine and
uh, through using our oh, water, that,
that was one of those
things that started to, uh,
inspire me to look at our water usage
and uh, make something like fog point.
I'll get there in a few though.
I was talking about our fruit and our
wine and that's been one of my favorite
parts of moving from whiskey and moving
from Colorado to California is our
collaboration with our local farmers.
When I first got here and I saw all of
the really interesting produce that's at
the farmer's market year round,
it inspires us to continue
to make new vodkas and our,
our partnership with those farmers as
we do this is so integral to everything
that we do. And the drought has had
a huge, huge impact on our farmers.
So this is a really important time for
us to talk about water and drought and
the water cycle and its impact on
everything we do in California.
So the drought officially ended in March.
I know the rain was terrible
and we're all very tired of it,
but it helped us to get out of this six
year drought cycle that over the course
of the last six years has caused a lot
of impact on California. For example,
last year the drought caused California
$3 million and 102 million trees died
over the course of that
six year drought periods.
So that's a little bit
of the impact globally,
but the farmers are really paying a
heavy price. Um, on this drought it's,
it's important to remember that California
is an agricultural center for the US
and it's our biggest
agricultural producer.
There's more than 200
crops grown in California.
So drought and farmers
definitely go hand in hand.
The thing that I kept hearing as we
were talking with our farmers is we're
sourcing our fruits for our VOD cause
it's how the drought is impacting all of
our fruit quality.
And our fruit availability.
Plus it's impacting me because I need
water to make my pocket. Like I said,
they're 60% water and vodka water adds
to the overall character of what we're
making. So the final package
of a vodka is that distillate.
We've distilled up to 190 proof.
Any process that we do.
So any infusion or mass aeration of our
fruits are botanicals if we're making a
flavored expression.
And then of course water.
The characteristic of the water is going
to have a huge impact on the final,
final product.
So the good news is we're talking about
water and these water issues is that
here in California as a community,
we like to all innovate as a group
to find solutions to these problems.
So individuals,
businesses,
we're all committed to chipping in and
making our state a better place and
helping sustainability. So would you tried
to do the same thing at hanger one? Um,
as a group we started looking for a new,
more sustainable source of water.
What's a way that we could
talk about this issue?
Raise awareness for the water crisis we
were having during the drought and make
a really tasty vodka at the same time.
That was our end goal.
So we searched for all kinds of different
processes and in that search, uh,
someone from our team came
across fog quest. Now Fuck,
this is a nonprofit that works worldwide
to collect fog for agricultural and
drinking water use. Uh, they work
in countries like Gla, Nepal,
Guatemala.
It sounds really cool and we realize that
fog is so iconic here in the bay area.
The solution for our water issue was
actually right in front of us this whole
time. Right? The question is, could
we actually use fog to make vodka?
Sounds like a really cool idea.
Is it actually something we can do?
So we decided to reach out
to the experts at fog quest.
So Chris here is that a local thug expert?
Chris has been volunteering with fog
quest for the last four years and he has
been instrumental in this project for
us. We've actually learned so much, um,
visiting the fog collectors with Chris
and learning about how fog is graded in
California. And, uh, how's a way that we
might be able to collect it? So Chris,
tell us a little bit about
fog please. Excellent. Oh, hi.
Like Katie said,
I'm a volunteer with the charity fog,
west sustainable water solutions.
And a fuck [inaudible]
mission is to provide water
to people in remote locations
using fog. And right
now fog quest has, uh,
projects in eight countries supplying
significant amount of water. Nope.
Like Hailey said,
they brought me here to explain a
little bit about the fog because it's,
it's kind of bewildering and,
uh,
want to try to explain how this
mechanism works. And the first thing,
first question I want to answer
is, you know, what is the fog?
And out here in the bay area,
the most prolific kind of fog that
we see as the fog from the ocean,
that puck comes off the ocean and that
is technically called a advection fog.
And advection means movement.
And so the way the fog is generated from
the ocean is warm air moves across the
cool ocean.
And as that air is cool,
it Ho it cannot hold as much water.
So the air becomes super saturated
and then as you're cools,
even further water droplets are forming.
So that's the mechanism for generating
fog, for generating ocean fog.
That's, and this ocean fog is the
starting point for fog collection. Uh,
in most areas.
And in one area we're fond quest has
the largest network of fog collectors.
It's in a remote village in Guatemala.
The advection fog is the starting point
in this village of fuck quest has around
35 large fog collectors and that occupies
a collection surface of around 15,000
square feet.
So that's about a third of a football
field vertically posted like billboards.
And those collectors produced around 1800
gallons of water a day during the dry
season. Uh, this subnetwork
by fog, fog quest,
it's a minimalist network.
It's designed to be rather inexpensive.
And also it's a passive technology
and so it doesn't require any energy.
And so for the people,
this one village,
the fog is a very positive
aspect in their life.
Now out here in the bay area,
people have a little more
mixed feelings about the fog.
Sometimes the fog will cause
traffic delays or airport delays.
But also during the summertime,
the fog can cool off an entire
city or an entire county.
And so if you think about it,
for the fog to have an
impact over a square miles,
there's a lot of energy in the fog.
There's a lot of cold water.
It's just difficult to acquire that water.
So hope that helps a little bit.
Now the pro,
the process for fog collection
is pretty straight forward.
What has to happen is fog
has to be blown through a,
through a mesh for several hours and then,
and then water is trapped on the Mesh
and it's eventually collected in a tank.
So how does,
I want to explain a little bit
more about why this works and uh,
the starting point to
understanding why this,
why this system works is I can
explain a little bit more about fog.
And the most important aspect of fog is
that the droplets and fog or microscopic,
there are about 100 times smaller
than a raindrop. So raindrops,
their trajectory usually is vertical.
They're falling,
they're falling from the cloud to the
ground. Fog droplets tend to float,
they move horizontally.
So any fog collectors will be posted in
a vertical fashion to try and maximize
the fog going through the material.
So the process, like I said, is
it's pretty straight forward. Uh,
fog droplets impact the mesh then may
get trapped and they stopped moving and
over time the mesh becomes waterlogged
and then larger droplets fall from the
Mesh into a trough and then
into a collection tank.
So basically what these fog collectors
are doing is they're converting the small
microscopic droplets and fog and the
larger droplets, which weekend down,
plumb into a tank.
Okay.
And one tool that fog researchers use
is called the standard fog collector.
A standard fog collector is,
uh,
can measure the fog collection
efficiency in a particular area. Uh,
and last year, uh, with, for s
for the fog, Bob could project,
we mainly use the standard fog collectors.
Also,
the researchers are commonly used them.
And from June through September,
this one,
small fog collector average,
uh, over a gallon a day,
pretty stove or a gallon a day.
During the fog season at Sutro tower?
No. Um, these standard fog collectors,
because researchers use them,
they're made to standard
specifications and standards sizes.
The main component on the fog collector
is one square meter metal frame.
And then that metal frame is wrapped
in a specific type of shade cloth.
There's two layers of shade cloth that
goes to the metal frame that makes up the
fog collection panel.
Then the fog collection panel was
lifted two meters off the ground.
It's also anchored in
place with Guidewire's.
The shade cloth that we use for
the standard fog collectors.
A was studied for around 10 years and
it was this particular shade cloth with
Rochelle.
We've and a 35% shade coefficient was
determined to be the most optimal material
for fog collection to high elevations.
Um,
and if you look at the shade cloth,
a little hard to see right here.
But there were shell,
we formed the triangle
and that facilitates water
shedding off the material.
And also that triangle pattern is similar
to the branch and needle structure on
redwood trees.
It's very similar.
So there's a lot of bio mimicry
going on in fog collection.
And a big topic of research is a lot of,
a lot of researchers and schools are
trying to develop materials which are more
efficient than the standard
fog collection material.
And for this project,
for this upcoming year,
we have several standard fog collectors
that we're using and we're also using a
larger fog collector with one
of these more exotic materials.
So it'll be interesting
to see what happens.
So we learned a ton from working fog crest
quest and Chris and it turns out that
fog collection is actually like the
perfect bay area solution to our bay area
water problem.
So we worked with Chris and fog quest to
build in strategically placed these fog
collectors throughout the bay.
Now Chris is monitoring three
fog collectors at Sutro tower.
This is actually a photo
of one of our collectors,
so you can see at the base of the tower.
Um,
and then we have the fog farm that was
recently installed at a farm in half Moon
Bay. Um, Chris, can you tell us why it
fog collectors at Sutro Tower? Make sense?
Sure, um, well to do fog
collection successfully,
it does require a very specific set
of geographic characteristics be met.
And one thing that's a little
counterintuitive is we're
using the advection fog,
the ocean fog.
But one the main criteria that fog post
requires requires is the fog collectors
should be placed at around two
thirds the height of the fog bank.
So in the bay area, that means generally
around a thousand feet up. And uh,
this is because,
because the fog collection is passive,
the fog an additional is
condensation step is required.
And as the fog from the ocean travels
up the hill co more condensation occurs
and the fog because more water depths.
So that's one requirement.
Another requirement is a
proximity to the ocean.
It's generally recommended that the fog
collectors should be installed within
five miles of the ocean.
And another requirement is generally
a free path for the fog to go from the
ocean to the net.
Now these characteristics in the bay area
are very difficult to reach because we
have a real estate and vegetation that's,
that's always occupying space. So it's,
it's really a matter of compromises.
Other important factors that we look
at when we're seeing if something,
if fuck collectible will work
is if there's a change in the,
in the plant and ecology.
If there's really lush green ferns
or a lot of moss on a tree during the
summertime, it's pretty likely there's
going to be fog in that area. Also,
you can use just physical examples like
if you're driving through an area and
you have to try on your windshield wipers,
that's an area that is,
has a lot of fog. And another,
another cue is from nature.
We can study the fog drip that comes off
the trees and if there's a significant
amount of water under a tree, that's a
good clue that fog collection will work.
And uh, to really, uh, to, to
combine all these characteristics.
I noticed that it,
the one tool the researchers uses
Google earth cause it can pull up the
elevation, the proximity to the
ocean and you can see the obstacles.
So that's pretty interesting.
Awesome.
So last summer suit,
your towers fog collectors were able
to collect about 350 gallons during the
high fog season. So just a little
idea of how much water we can get.
So it's now time for a little bit
of audience participation. Um,
you guys have all got a vial with you.
Um,
this is a sample of the water collected
at Sutro tower over the last couple of
days.
So I'd like to take this opportunity to
taste this fog so we can understand how
the flavor of this waters impacts the
final flavor profile of the vodka.
And we'll taste the vodka
in just a moment. Um,
so go ahead and get this water a sip.
So the water's collected,
it's brought to the hangar in
tanks. Um, we then carbon filter it,
boil it and carbon filtered a second time.
Now the filtration steps really important
because we are collecting fog and
these nice,
beautiful nature areas that have things
like leaves and dust that might be able
to fall into the fog tanks. So we want
to remove any of those particulates. Um,
we then boil to ensure the water sanitary
and just filter one more time to make
sure it's nice and clean. Um, once
we've been through these steps,
we send the water out to a laboratory for
analysis and it turns out that the fog
water is actually cleaner. And then
the average tap water in the bay area.
However,
as you guys are tasting it,
you'll notice it does have
its own character to it.
So the thing that I really like about
the water is that mineral note that you
get there. It reminds me a lot of
hiking. I'm really into hiking.
And when you're outside on a nice warm
day after a damp morning or a rainstorm
and you can smell the warm wet stones
of like river or something as you're
crossing by, that's exactly what
the fog water reminds me of.
It also is a slight salty
mineral characteristic to it.
I don't know if that comes from the ocean.
I like to think that it does. Awesome.
So we've talked a lot about the water.
What are we just dealing to make
this vodka? We're using wine.
We decided to partner with Bonny doon
vineyards cause we decided if we're gonna
make this a sustainable vodka,
we're going to do this.
We want to really do it now.
Randall Graham and the Bonny Doon team
really inspired me with their wine making
techniques. They're huge into
sustainable biodynamic farming.
And when I'm talking
about biodynamic farming,
I'm talking about synchronizing
the viticultural process
with the natural cycles
of the plants and of nature so
that that's, it's a low impact,
natural way to farm things like bringing
in symbiotic plants and animals to
augment the growing conditions of the
grapes instead of using artificial
elements,
things like fertilizers and pesticides.
So we have these really great sustainable,
delicious grapes that are turned into
a wine as Randall puts it with minimal
human intervention.
So we worked with the entire 2012 vintage
of Bonnie Dunes, Lyssa garb, long Klein.
This is a white wine blend
that's made of Piquepoul,
Roussanne and Grenache Blanc.
We brought all of the
wine to the distillery and
distilled it up to 190 proof
and then used nothing but pure California
cop fog water to cut that bod come
back down to 80 proof and poof, thug
point vodka, this delicious stuff,
which you guys all happened
to have a taste of.
So now the moment you've been waiting for,
we've been talking all morning,
you're here to taste vodka. Um,
so when I'm tasting of vodka,
I like to start with
nosing it. Okay? It gives,
it gives my mind in my palette a
preview of what's about to happen.
You guys don't need the swirl. This, I
know we're all very used to wine tasting,
but there's a lot more alcohol in here.
Then there isn't a wine and swirling.
It is going to make that volatile
alcohol rise up off the surface.
When you knows it, you'll get less of
the lovely notes and a lot more alcohol.
So no swirling,
but go ahead and take a nose.
Breathe in through your nose
and mouth at the same time.
That error rates that alcohol sent a
little bit so you can start to notice the
characteristics coming off of the vodka.
Now you can smell that mineral
Enos you get from the water,
but there's also a little
bit of floral characteristic.
Also a little bit of sweetness.
Next,
go ahead and take a small
step from your vodka.
This is going to prime your palate
and cleanse it. It's awesome.
You guys eaten salads back there. Don't
want your body, it tastes like salad.
So this step we'll go ahead and and
cleanse and get you ready and on the next
sip and takes slightly larger sip and
allow yourself to really experience the
texture of the vodka.
The nice rounded mouthfeel and all of
those flavor notes will start to come out.
Floral notes,
sweetness,
making a vodka from 100% wine was
something I was really excited to do.
Our straight vodka combines a grain
and great profile to make a really
interesting complex expression,
but so much of that sweetness and
that softness comes from the grape.
So to have 100% great fod can make spray.
Really dare I say robust flavored vodka.
I'll right
after vodka tasting. A little bit
of fun factoids about fog points.
So we used a vintage of wine and all
the fog water we could collect for six
months. And then doing that we were
able to make 2,472 bottles of fog point.
So this is a really limited edition vodka.
Um,
we released it here in California and
then a couple select areas throughout the
country and the response was awesome.
It was really exciting to see spirits
nerds and people that are really into the,
uh,
the distilling industry like it.
But to see average people
really getting into it,
to everyone across the board thought this
was a really cool idea and I think it
really brought forth the conversation
about water conservation and collecting
fog.
We created bark pro program to different
bartenders throughout the country to
make fog point Martinis on.
We actually just enjoyed one right by
the bay bridge over there at epic State
Council yesterday.
Really delicious way to taste the vodka.
And that salted characteristic makes
a pair really well with seafood,
which is perfect because we have a
lot of that here in the bay area. Um,
the last fun note is that we donated
the profits from fog point sales, uh,
back to fog quest and to what other
water conservation organizations to push
this conversation forward and help
facilitate more research into how fog
collection could become a viable solution
for some of this water crisis that
we've been experiencing.
And I understand that it really has
pushed the conversation forward.
Yes, there's are, because of this project,
I've been introduced to numerous groups
of researchers and they're interested
more in talking with hangar one because
there are still supportive of that
community. We've also met some
businesses that are using fog. Um,
I'll talk about them in a bit, but
some of the researchers that I've been,
we've hang, hang on. One is now
been associated with our, uh,
out of the U S gs.
They at least your toward side.
She works in the restaurant
regional science center,
got a down the street at Menlo Park and
which one aspect of her research is to
compile satellite data during this over
several years during the summertime.
And she overlays those satellite
images and I was able to get,
get an estimate of the approximate fog
and low coastal cloud concentrations in
an area. This is a real good tool, a
good starting point for fog researchers.
And this,
this map is of the uh,
point Ray's area and if you're
familiar with kind of the North Bay,
you can see that the, that
the, the higher the white parts
are kind of in the Marin headlands
and then upper up by point race.
And once again, if we were to cross
this map with the other characteristics,
especially using Google earth,
uh, it becomes, you're able,
we're able to pinpoint
locations much better.
Other researchers that we've met a
include ecologists and Botanists,
some this is,
some ecologists are studying the fog drip
off the trees and they found that it's
in some locations, especially on
the ridge line above half Moon Bay,
that the fog drip off the trees can
account for twice as much water as comes
during the rainy season.
This image here is another is an
image from Alicia toward neurosis,
a standard fog collectors up in
the mid peninsula research area.
And what she has there is,
like I said,
researchers are trying to study
different Mesh to see which ones are more
effective.
And so she has an array up and there's
going to be a journal article out shortly,
uh,
combining this evaluation along with
several other evaluations along the coast
of California.
But what's really fascinating is we met
a botanist who was doing research out of
Santa Barbara and she focused,
she set up some standard fog collectors
at a strawberry farm and other biology
type equipment.
And she was able to measure
how efficiently plants
were transporting water and
doing photosynthesis.
And she was able to prove that after a
fog event at these particular strawberry
farms, the w the strawberries
required less water to thrive.
And that's really interesting,
especially if you combine that fact
with Alicia tour grosses maps where they
show that Salinas valley where there's
a lot of these farm lettuce and
strawberry farms, that's
prime fog area. So, um,
there's a lot of interesting, uh, studies
of fog not really related to collecting,
collecting the water,
but ecologist or studying and botanists
are studying it and also toxicologists
are studying it. Um, so now, uh,
some of the businesses we've met,
uh, with this project include, uh,
a guy who sold us who sold hangar one,
the first ever fog collector of
this style in the United States.
Uh,
we met Michael Donahue with this company
for two h two o and he is a distributor
of these German engineered
style fog collector,
which has been trademarked and branded.
The Cloud Fisher fog collectors,
uh, they use, like I say,
a more exotic mesh and they're also,
they have an aspect of German engineering
where there they're more robust than
the fog quest fog collectors.
But there's also, um,
more money involved in this,
in the materials.
So it's interesting to see the
different charities compete for once.
One's a highly engineered device and one's
more of a minimalist device. Now this,
those fog collectors that we saw,
um,
have been installed successfully and
Morocco and in 2018 with the support of a
couple of Moroccan charities
and the support of a Ger,
German government, these,
these Claude Fisher style fog collectors
are estimated to be the new largest fog
collector network.
There's supposed to be larger than the
one block west has up in Guatemala.
So it'll be interesting to see if
they can accomplish that by 2018.
So through talking with these
researchers and these businesses,
I really think that fog point has,
has established a dialogue and we can,
it'll be interesting to see where
we go forward from here with water
conservation and fog studies
and the work on the farms. Yeah.
Very cool.
Awesome. So a little bit in closing, um,
I hope you guys didn't see that innovation
and fresh thinking are at the center
of pretty much everything
we do at hanger one.
So we were so excited to be
invited to Google. You know,
Google is thought of as a
really progressive company
that's on the forefront of,
of human ingenuity, I
would say. And so it's,
it's really exciting to be able to come
here and talk to you guys about fog
point. Um, I hope I've changed your
perception of what you're drinking.
So next time you're out at happy hour,
you can think about how much water is in
this vodka and where did it come from.
Um, we do welcome your thoughts
though. We're always innovating.
We're always looking for new ways to
make vodka and new things to make vodka
from.
So please feel free to reach out with to
me if you guys have any ideas about any,
it's sort of fun projects
we could go forth on,
any issues we could address in
the vodka making worlds. Um,
and also lastly like to invite all
of you, um, we pass a little car,
but please come visit
us at the distillery.
We're located just up the way at the
Alameda Naval Air Station and we'd love to
have you so you can see our
equipment, learn about our
process, tastes, fog point,
hangar one, and some of our
limited edition Bod Vodkas. So, uh,
thank you guys very much.
I'd like to open it up for questions
if anyone has any questions. Yes,
it's a great question.
Well,
like I said,
the researchers from Stanford or studying
or trying to study the characteristics
which produce a lot of fog
drip. And so there, there,
there were at that stage in 2015 I
know the research is ongoing now.
I'm not sure what you mean by what
the impact on the ecosystem is.
They won what they're,
what the researchers are able to do
other than study the fog drip is they're
able to do an isotope analysis of the
water of the water table from well water
and they can identify how much of the
water recently came from fog and how much
of the water came from rain.
And there has been,
once again a surprising
in some watersheds,
especially along the coast are talking
about like the crystal springs watershed,
uh, just, uh, east of half
Moon Bay. That they're, the,
I still analysis of that water table
shows that the fog has a very significant
impact on that watershed. Yeah. Well,
um, that's, that's a good question. The,
of course if you were to layer fog
nets everywhere, it would probably,
it could have an impact, but generally
the fog is so spread out and it's,
it does encompass such a,
such a high and wide area
that it would be difficult to,
to remove a large amount of water.
But an obvious thing to do with the
reason I think that the u s gs is involved
in mapping this out is they
could potentially regulate
it and set up the permit
system. So people were removing the
water in a sustainable manner. Isn't the,
the fog that you get near the bay,
wouldn't it have salt in it?
Well,
um,
certainly there's an impact on the fog
from the waves breaking action and that
that does introduce different,
um, chemicals into the fog.
Now as the, as the fog
travels up a hill, like I say,
far quest recommends,
uh,
installing the fog nets at a
high elevation. Most of your,
most of the impurities in
the fog dropout. And, uh,
in order to provide water
to these remote communities,
the fog water had to be tested
and it's been tested for decades.
And it is most generally it meets the
criteria set by the UN for clean water,
especially compared to a groundwater
and some of these more remote areas.
But yeah, there, there is a,
there is an impact there and it's due
mainly to the wave action. That's what,
that's the point of exposure.
That's where the fog changes
characteristics is right
when it crosses the beach.
So
how much water does a single
catcher get an on a good day? Yes.
Yup. Like a Sutro tower I think
is a good optimum location in the,
in the bay area. And last summer
during our heavy fog period,
it averaged just over a gallon per day.
And that's one squared meter.
Usually that's it.
Usually they're measured in gallons
or liters per day per square meter.
So a little over four,
four liters per day.
Awesome.
We put up a standard fog collection
collector at the distillery in Alameda as
well. Um, mainly because
people want to see them,
but also we were kind of interested
how much water we would collect.
We get about a half a liter a day,
maybe a leader on a really good day.
So we use it to help water plants,
but we're not in the optimal
area like Sutro tower.
Does it distillery doing even make any,
uh, naturally flavored vodkas. Yes.
All of our VOD because
they're naturally flavored.
So any of our flavored vodkas that you
will taste are made by mass rating,
fruits and botanicals and
hundred 90 proof spirit. Um,
we then save that infusion
and take the fruit out.
And if you've ever made
infused vodka home,
you know that when you take the food out,
you have really bluesy fruit left,
right? We don't want to let
that alcohol go to waste.
So we take the fruit and we put it back
into our pot still with a little water
and then distill the alcohol out of
the fruit. And during that process,
whatever oils and compounds that were
in our botanicals that the alcohol
couldn't pull out the heat from the still
breaks down and pulls through and that
just lit that distillate and infusion
are then used to flavor the final vodka.
And so that's why our
vodkas tastes so fresh.
We work with our farmers
at the peak of freshness.
They deliver all of the fruit
for the year. So for example,
when we do Buddha's hands, they're
in season, December, January,
I'm in Buda hand land during that time
and then I don't touch Buddha's hands for
the rest of the year. So we do all
of our infusions and distillate,
it's more seasonally like a winery and
then blend and batch them throughout the
year so that we do have
that fresh flavored vodka.
That's the question. Um, so fog
point did sell very quickly.
It was so popular.
It is sold out almost everywhere.
There's a shop located at the
distillery that as a few bottles left.
And as far as I know,
those are the last few. Um,
the good news is that with
Chris's help and our new fog farm,
we're working on another
expression of fog point.
It will be a little bit different
than the current one. We're, we're,
we're collecting fog
from a different area,
so there may be a slightly different
flavor profile there and we're exploring
what other types of wine we
might be able to use as well.
Okay.
Any other questions guys?
How much does the standard
fog catcher costs? Oh,
that's a great question.
Oh
yeah. Well, uh, like I said, the
materials using the fog quest design, uh,
like the one we had,
I showed up at Sutro tower,
they use an abs post system to hold
them up. So it's relatively inexpensive,
around $300. Uh, and the
academics, you steel posts,
they're a little more expensive.
Now that's not including any measurement
equipment. Usually the accurate boot,
the SFC array that I showed that Alicia
had up here, it had a tipping bucket,
rain gauges on there or they can,
they can monitor in real time how
much the water's being produced.
That adds another three or $400 per unit.
So it can get expensive.
But the idea is that
these can be assembled
by people who,
who have few resources.
So it should be relatively feasible.
As I understand it too,
once we've determined the Neri
is good for fog collection,
it's very easy to put it in an inexpensive
fog collector there cause they know
they're going to get good
thought. Right. Yeah.
That's the really the, the, the first
step is to put a smaller one up, test it,
verify and then go larger.
So speaking about fog and you know,
I guess there's a certain
height of the farm,
like it won't go past a certain
altitude or whatever. Is that,
is that taken into consideration when
you're making the fog collectors?
Like is there an optimal height of
the fog collector that you've seen?
Like the ones that are produced,
um,
being that maybe if it's too tall it will
evaporate before it gets collected or
something like that?
Yeah,
well certainly the fog collectors,
both the standard fog collectors at
larger collection collection nets date,
it's important to have them a couple
meters off the ground because there's a
boundary layer right on the ground and
there's a lot of fluid dynamics involved
in fog collection and the fluid dynamics,
people say that the closer
to the ground you get,
the more poor the performances.
So there's that question
and generally the theirs,
so they're usually about two
meters up off the ground.
And this larger system we had it,
it went about three meters up after that.
And, uh, in order to, like I say, in
order to find the optimum elevation, uh,
generally you don't try and raise
the fog net up to the elevation.
You try and get the right height land
and then just put it two or three meters
up cause it's a lot easier to construct
a then trying to raise it really high up.
But,
um,
there are opportunities to install
fog collectors like on rooftops,
but then those are much higher.
But then you have another fluid dynamic
problem where the fog hits the building
and it kind of shoots over the top.
So we're involved with fluid dynamics
people to try and create a spoiler or
something that will force the fog
into the net. But that's, that's a,
that's a problem that's going to take
several decades probably to solve.
Okay.
How is the vodka affected,
if at all, by geographically
where the fog is collected?
That's a great question. So for the
fog point that we tasted today, um,
we collected fog from a couple locations
including Berkeley, Tilden Park,
Sutro tower, and we had a few collectors
for a while in the Presidio. Um,
because we were so new to collecting
fog and because we were collecting such
small amounts day by day, uh, we
added them all to the same tank.
So the flavor profile of the fog is how
I know the flavor profile of the fog to
be. And I never had the opportunity to
taste the fog from different collectors
separately until just recently.
I'm finding that the water's very similar,
but there definitely is a little
bit of shift from place to place.
I had never thought of,
you're talking about fog terroir
at this point in my career,
but you know what happens? Um, so yes at
the, the flavor differences is very minor,
I'm finding here in California,
but I'd be really interested to see
how fog water might taste different and
Guatemala or Morocco than what we
can get here in northern California.
So I want to just know
if there's a way to, um,
for you to tell us how long does it
usually takes for a new flavor of vodka
comes off or in this case when you develop
the foc one Bucca how long did this
whole planning process happened
from beginning to the end?
That's a great question. So, um,
when we do a lot of
experimentation at the distillery,
I often find myself going to the farmer's
market and finding some really awesome
fruit or botanical we want
to play with. Um, so there's,
there's always a sort of research,
new product development time involved
where we really want to dial in the vodka
itself and how delicious it is going
to be. Um, once we get to that point,
there's a lot of other things involved.
You know, things like package design,
the federal government has to approve
our labels, uh, things like that.
So it can take quite awhile to get all
those things together and to get the
bottling materials and, and whatnot. Um,
but it does vary from product to product.
Uh, some take a lot less time to
plan fog point. Unfortunately,
it took quite a while because we had
the lead time to collect all this water.
So it was,
it was kind of an ongoing experiment
for us and a really exciting day when we
had the opportunity to actually
say, here's the vodka, here it is.
Go out and taste it guys.
Sorry.
Yup.
So the question is,
what is your advice for someone interested
in becoming a master distiller with
education avenues?
Would you recommend?
That's a really awesome question because
I got into distilling a little bit by
mistake, if you will. Um, I'm very
lucky that I found my passion this way.
I have an art degree and uh,
it was during a gap in employment that I
was looking for something fun to do and
stumbled upon a distilling. I was really
into craft beer. So it, it drove me there,
but I never knew how much I'd love to
stealing and how interested in the science
of distilling would be.
Um,
I'm hoping seeing more people
out doing things like throwing,
distilling winemaking, um, drives
people towards stem a little bit more.
Cause I think understanding science and
engineering is really helpful. Chemistry,
especially as a distiller.
But there is a lot of art involved.
So people from all walks of life are
involved in this industry. And there's,
there's a lot that folks can
contribute from anywhere.
So I say if you're interested in
distilling or learning to distill on,
just to get out there and learn,
read as much as you can and,
and involve yourself in the industry.
Cause you never know when there's
going to be a job opportunity and an
opportunity to learn.
Okay.
Awesome. Thank you. Thank you
guys. A round of applause.
[inaudible].